okay time for a YouTube update and I
apologize I don't have my uh what are
you young uns call it the gimbal the
gimbal I'm back to using just my my
standard shoulder which no debt will
build up with lactic acid so I apologize
for the instability if it's particularly
acidic and lactic II I'm actually
visiting some family here on a beautiful
Lake Michigan a couple of things I know
that some of you here already already my
shoulders tired I am out of shape we're
waiting I know some of you were waiting
for the Gyeonggi climate strike video to
go up tonight apologize that'll be going
up tomorrow a couple of reasons there
were some technical difficulties in
offloading the footage and I also
thought this warranted an update on the
YouTube situation the YouTube twenty20
election blacklist so first thing I want
to thank everybody out there thank you
so much to you guys who sent in
screenshots who did the three I mean you
basically did the legwork for us you
know you are an absolute goldmine of
data that businesses would pay millions
upon millions of dollars to access
probably in breaching privacy laws a
gross breach of privacy laws but you're
able to do some of the research that we
can't and there have been some changes
to YouTube to the blacklisting just let
you guys know I know there been some
rumors out there that we lied or we
manipulated screenshots well listen
there's been some changes where if you
search just generically this channel now
YouTube has made some specific changes I
don't know if they were in response to
what we've done I have no idea I'm not
implying that where it shows the most
recent uploads or popular uploads which
was not the case before but it's also
not consistent across all platforms but
there was something really peculiar in
in I would say very concerning that we
found out regarding the youtube search
results so as we talked about last week
if you searched steven crowder changed
my mind
you were about 70 results in before you
found one of my videos maybe it was
twenty results depended on what time of
day you were searching I guess but the
point is there were a lot of other
channels and other networks that popped
up before and this by the way all
started with someone who works with me
wanting to send a friend to go out to
change my mind video
and we just did yeah I just Search
Search Search steven crowder changed my
mind and it should pop up and they said
it's not so keep in mind this this sort
of surfaced at least captured our
attention organically so a lot of you
ran these searches and we did notice
some inconsistencies some people were
saying hey listen you're you're lying
you're the boy who cried you tube here
which we never want to be and we're
sending in screenshots saying showing
verifiably irrefutably that if they
search steven crowder changement mind
that our channel was popping up that's a
good thing but then other people were
showing us the opposite that it was not
the case so we did some digging and we
found something out the results as far
as the blacklisting the ghosting like a
bad date from tinder of this channel
what's happening only in the United
States that's what we suspected anyway
so he ran some searches identical
general video searches steven crowder
changed my mind or the title of the
video you know very specific to try and
leave little room for error in in places
like Spain I know we had a viewer out
there user you know who you are who
searched it in Spain and it was fine
same thing in Russia funny enough and
funnily enough funny enough it seems
like funny enough to I don't know I
don't know grammar nazis you let me know
give me a hard time just like the fat
shaming so it showed up but then when we
switch to VPN and certain ran a search
in the united states it didn't show up
and the same thing every time we tried
to search with specificity content from
this channel so it was specifically
blacklisted throttled only in the united
states
meaning content was more freely
accessible in places like Russia
I believe the Ukraine get a fan from the
Ukraine don't quote me on that but I
know for sure Russia and Spain then here
in the United States now why would that
be I don't know why it would be but I I
don't want to hear what you guys think I
never want to be paranoid or
conspiratorial but I can't imagine a
world in which the biggest conservative
YouTube channel
is throttled blacklisted ghosted emitted
from search results however however you
want to refer to it but exclusively in
the United States I can't imagine a
world in which that's the case unless
there is someone directly trying to put
their thumb on the scales of the
election there could be another reason
you guys let me know but again it would
seem to me that it should be most free
and open in the United States
I can understand in places like Canada
or the UK where they have hate speech
laws if the government is leaning on
YouTube to make sure that they acquiesce
to someone not getting someone not
getting offended for example in the UK
from someone doing a karaoke song of
kung-fu fighting so it was actually put
in jail for that that's a real thing but
the United States is the last bastion of
freedom where we do have freedom of
speech so first to be throttled
exclusively in the United States and not
places like Spain Russia Canada was
absolutely bizarre to us and we're doing
some digging I would like please send me
screenshots follow me on Twitter ed s
Crowder because we don't reveal
everything here on YouTube I don't want
to be just bombarding you with YouTube
updates here I'd really rather focus on
creating more content but we also want
to make sure that if we create content
we're able to reach you and that's why
please just save this page bookmark at
second every day we do videos every
single day if you haven't joined mug
club or you can't afford it yet just
just check in every day because we don't
know when notifications or subscriptions
work and that's kind of the point here's
we never know when anything works and
that's why we need you to send in more
data search other controversial topics
in other countries because here's one
thing it doesn't stop with us it doesn't
stop with conservatives in the United
States right if they can do it here for
politically expedient purposes they can
do it anywhere it could lead to LGBTQ
videos being censored in Middle Eastern
countries it could lead to videos that
are critical of the Israeli government
being blacklisted from searches in
Israel I it could lead to searching for
Hong Kong protesters being completely
barred and in places like like China and
I'm not talking about the government
restricting access
I'm talking about potentially YouTube
doing that because that's all we're
seeing in the United States we surely
don't see any evidence that the
government has stepped in and asked them
to list you know what that crowd of gay
or absurd
his truck tops was was what step too far
get out of here I have no idea but I
certainly haven't seen any evidence of
that but let me let me present a
hypothetical scenario to you here this
is a thought exercise just to sort of
put the value or some sort of value some
context on the effect that this could
happen an election let's say Russia okay
we always talk about Russia let's start
with that Russia they meddled in the
United States election well to the best
of our ability to tell all the evidence
points toward the fact that Russia spent
a few thousand dollars on Facebook ads
right to try and cause chaos in the
United States election okay let's accept
that is true or I don't want to argue
about Russia right now okay so let me
ask you this let's say in this
hypothetical world I'm a Russian agent
watch that'll be clipped I'm a Russian
agent right I'm a Russian agent that's
gonna be clipped but let's say in this
hypothetical world I'm a Russian agent
okay this channel is nothing but
pro-russia propaganda Pro KGB pro-putin
propaganda okay doing the the bidding of
the Russian government with four million
subscribers close to a billion plays let
me ask you this if they spent a few
thousand dollars on Facebook ads which
had a marginal effect if any at all how
much do you think they would spend to
run a channel like this to have a
channel before we were well on our way
to five million subscribers should have
been there in June until the new
algorithmic changes and the Box said
pocalypse how much do you think the
Russian government would pay to have a
channel of four million subscribers five
million subscribers a billion plays five
million 10 million 20 million now let's
flip it let's say that the Russian
government wanted to make sure that only
their point of view is presented okay
they wanted to try and tip the scales on
new media big tech and let's say that
this channel as opposed to being a
Russian agent this channel was the
biggest thorn in the side of the Russian
government so this channel was the
biggest whistleblower with documentation
with evidence constantly going up
against a corrupt Russian government and
exposing their corruption now let's say
there was an opportunity for the Russian
government to eliminate a channel with
four or five million subscribers a
billion place it could completely wipe
out their biggest detractor
how much do you think they'd spend for
that five million ten million 50 million
that's just so I just present that
thought exercise to show you how
important and how valuable this digital
real estate is in the upcoming elections
and frankly in molding the views of a
generation there are people in positions
of power who absolutely do want to pinch
the valve of the flow of information and
like it or not I mean listen this is
this is kind of a blueprint for
conservatives on YouTube and when you
look at the totality of the evidence
what happened after the Vox had
pocalypse what's been happening with a
lot of people on YouTube but what's been
happening happening specifically with
search results what's been happening
specifically with very specific titles
and tags a few searching our stuff not
showing up and it happening exclusively
in the United States that is a political
social impact that is scary that can be
done to anyone and I don't know if it's
deliberate or not and I would love to
know what you think what do you think
it's deliberate whether you think it's
just something that maybe got lost in
the shuffle but I do know this whether
it's deliberate whether it's just
oversight that the one point of view on
YouTube expressing a more traditionalist
conservative viewpoint certainly in the
realm of comedy late night whatever it
is the fact remains that this channel is
throttled and not treated the same as
other channels coming up to an election
time whether it's deliberate or its
oversight it doesn't matter anymore it
doesn't matter it's too important and
it's wrong either way and something has
to be done so right now we're just in
the information gathering process I know
we've been we've been saying that for a
long time but we want to make an
informed decision and of course we're
hangout and trying to communicate with
people at YouTube you know we always try
to want to work these things out as
amicably as possible but to be armed
with as much information as possible is
the way you can best help us right now
it's been incredibly helpful over the
last week and I would really appreciate
it if you send some more because we'll
be putting all this in our file and
updating you soon
tomorrow Gyeonggi climate strike and see
you then